so what is the objective of the CV
review interview why are consulting
firms doing this type of interview at
all and the truth is usually the
consulting firms do not use this
interview section to sort out candidates
based on their CVS because this is what
already happened in the pre-selection
based on your written documents so the
fact that you got invited to the
interview the fact that you're now
sitting in a room with an interview of
the firm having this interview usually
already means that your CV was good
enough the HR department considered your
CVS to meet all the criteria to get
invited for the interview because
otherwise you wouldn't be